Olá tudo bem Aqui o Dr Alan Machado
Dutra médico há mais de 25 anos e eu vou
te falar hoje sobre um assunto que pode
parecer um pouco estranho à primeira
vista mas que eu achei muito
interessante compartilhar com vocês é
sobre o cheiro corporal o nosso cheiro
pessoal você vai se surpreender com o
que eu vou te dizer isso porque a forma
como cheiramos pode ser um espelho
revelador de nossa saúde capaz de
sinalizar desde leves até doenças mais
graves e eu vou contar Quais são as
principais doenças que alteram o nosso
odor e vou explicar Qual é o tipo de
Cheiro característico que essas doenças
exalam e por que que esse assunto é
importante imagine poder detectar sinais
precoces de doença de problemas de saúde
em pessoas próximas você que convive com
seu marido sua esposa filhos ou mesmo
seus pais idosos você pode de repente
notar um certo dor diferente neles um
cheiro que você não sentia antes e isso
pode indicar algum problema de saúde e
eu já começo compartilhando com vocês
uma história bem fascinante que vai
abrir nossos olhos pro poder
extraordinário do nosso sentido do
olfato e como às vezes ele pode nos
contar mais sobre nossa saúde do que nós
imaginamos a escocesa Joy mii é uma
mulher que tem um talento surpreendente
ela consegue perceber o cheiro da da
doença de Parkinson antes mesmo de
qualquer diagnóstico formal e tudo isso
começou com seu próprio marido ela notou
um odor peculiar nele algo que nunca
tinha sentido antes o seu marido começou
a exalar esse odor quando tinha por
volta dos 32 anos e pasmem amigos mais
de uma década depois ele foi
diagnosticado com a doença de Parkinson
em uma visita a um grupo de apoio para
pessoas com paxon ela também percebeu
que outros pacientes exalavam o mesmo
cheiro de seu marido aí a partir daí ela
se envolveu em estudos científicos que
buscava entender como que tinha esse
super poder olfativo e como poderia
contribuir para o diagnóstico precoce da
doença Olha que curioso né parece
mentira em um experimento científico
deram a Joy camisetas que haviam sido
usadas por pessoas com a doença e sem a
doença de paxon ela conseguiu
identificar corretamente os indivíduos
que tinham a doença apenas pelo cheiro e
o mais impressionante ainda é que ela
apontou uma camiseta de uma pessoa
Teoricamente de grupo saudável como
tendo o cheiro específico de paxon e na
época pensaram que ela tinha errado mas
alguns anos depois aquela pessoa foi
diagnosticada com a doença incrível
pessoal jo não tinha errado ela tinha
previsto
paxon Anos Antes naquela pessoa
Fantástico então a doença de paxon É um
distúrbio do sistema nervoso central
afeta o movimento provocando sintomas
como tremores rigidez da parte muscular
movimentos lentos a doença ela progride
com o tempo Podendo também afetar a
mente a fala a marcha e a postura então
as pesquisas mais recentes têm mostrado
que o odor característico associado ao
axon tende a se manifestar não nas
axilas mas na nuca e na região das
costas próximo as omoplatas e como é que
seria esse cheiro ele é descrito como um
cheiro de almiscar almiscarado um termo
que talvez não seja familiar para todos
mas basicamente é um aroma intenso e
profundo muitas vezes associado à Terra
como uma nuance quase am mandir ou algo
primitivamente animal tradicional ente o
alisca é um composto que era extraído de
animais para uso em perfumaria conhecido
por sua capacidade de fixar o cheiro e
por sua fragrância penetrante duradora o
aspecto mais intrigante aqui é que esse
cheiro almiscarado associado ao paxon
pode começar a se manifestar anos antes
dos sintomas motores clássicos da doença
se tornarem evidentes ou aparentes que
levaria o diagnóstico mais convencional
Mas você sabia que aa entre o odor
corporal e a detecção de doenças não é
coisa nova isso vem desde a antiguidade
na Grécia Antiga e na medicina
tradicional chinesa o olfato já era
reconhecido como uma ferramenta
essencial para diagnosticar várias
condições de saúde Imagine você médicos
daquela época usando o seu nariz para
guiar diagnóstico soua incrível e também
curioso não é mesmo por exemplo na
história existem registros de doenças
como um tipo de tuberculose
extrapulmonar conhecida Antigamente como
escrófula que era identificada pelo seu
cheiro característico semelhante a de
cerveja envelhecida ou ainda a febre
tifoide cujo diagnóstico era associado
ao cheiro de pão assado e até a febre
amarela era a tida como odor de carne
quase como estar dentro de um açougue
tudo isso é uma capacidade fascinante
que nos lembra de como no nosso corpo é
uma fonte rica de informações se
soubermos Como ouvir ou nesse caso Como
cheirar Então pessoal as infecções
representam uma causa comum de
alterações no rudor corporal e sua
influência pode se manifestar de várias
formas desde o hálito até a pele e o
suor a diversidade de bactérias e
microorganismos capazes de causar
infecções resulta em uma ampla Gama de
odores característicos por por exemplo
as infecções de boca bucais são uma
fonte bem conhecida de mau hálito com as
placas bacterianas desempenhando um
papel Central nesse processo infecções
por estafilococos por exemplo podem
produzir odores comparados a tênis sujo
ou queijo envelhecido a particularidade
desse odor vem da produção de diacetil
um composto com aroma manteigada
reconhecível que pode dar a pele um
cheiro estranho de manteiga já bactéria
esqu ericha Cole a e colle por outro
lado pode afetar o cheiro da urina dando
um aroma de fruta podre vinagre ou até
leite azedo esse odor peculiar é o
resultado da produção de indol formato
pela decomposição do aminoácido
triptofano pelas bactérias além disso a
h pilora helicobacter pilor conhecida
por causar úlceras estomacais E gastrite
pode ser responsável por um hálito
caracterizado pelo cheiro de ovo podre
ou enxofre devido a produção de sulfeto
de hidrogênio pela bactéria Então esse
gás é gerado quando hilor processa
compostos contendo enxofre no
estômago pessoal o hipertiroidismo traz
a luz outro aspecto fascinante da
interação entre doenças específicas e o
nosso cheiro corporal O hipertiroidismo
ocorre quando a glândula tiroide
trabalha demais fica hiperativa e produz
hormônios tiroidianos em excesso como os
hormônios tiroidianos desempenham um
papel fundamental na regulação do
metabolismo e de várias outras funções
corporais seu excesso de funcionamento
pode ter várias repercussões no
organismo um dos sinais marcantes do
hipertiroidismo é o aumento do suor
devido a aceleração do metabolismo o
corpo tenta se resfriar através da
transpiração que pode levar a um suor
mais intenso e mais frequente Então esse
aumento da transpiração pode contribuir
para um odor corporal mais acentuado
particularmente nas axilas virilhas e
pés onde as glândulas sudoríparas são
mais ativas Além disso O hipertiroidismo
pode provocar alterações no hálito
resultando no cheiro frutado semelhante
ao de acetona queela mesma usada paraa
retirada do esmalte da unha Então esse é
odor peculiar é uma consequência da
quebra acelerada de gorduras paraa
formação de energia esse processo que
gera acetonas como subproduto a acetona
acaba sendo formada pela quebra de
gordura então a presença de cetonas no
hálito é um indicador de que o corpo
está usando gordura como fonte primária
de energia uma característica comum em
Estados de metabolismo acelerado como é
o caso do hipertiroidismo se você nota
esse odor corporal mais forte hou uma
mudança no cheiro do seu hálito junto
com outros sintomas como perda de peso
sem explicação palpitações nervosismo
aumento da Fome mudanças de ciclo
menstrual Pode ser sim um sinal de
hipertiroidismo então é importante você
procurar assistência médica e investigar
a gota é uma forma específica de Artrite
que causa inflamação e dor aguda
principalmente nas articulações do dedão
do pé e também representa uma condição
de saúde que pode influenciar o dor
corporal desta vez afetando mais a urina
a causa da Gota é o acúmulo excessivo de
ácido úrico no corpo que pode
cristalizar as articulações e nos zins
também pode se acumular essas esses
cristais provocando episódios Dolorosos
de inflamação Então esse acúmulo de
ácido úrico pode alterar o cheiro da
urina porque quando o ácido úrico se
acumula em níveis elevados ele pode se
decompor em amônia que é um composto com
odor forte e desagradável portanto um
cheiro mais intenso de amônia na urina
pode ser um sinal indicativo de gota ou
de problemas relacionados ao excesso de
ácido úrico prosseguindo com a nossa
exploração de doenças que podem alterar
o odor corporal eu quero falar sobre o
Diabetes que é uma condição bem
conhecida no diabetes quando o corpo não
dispõe de insulina suficiente para
processar a glicose que circula no
sangue isso pode resultar em um aroma
bastante específico identificável um
hálito frutado ou similar a acetona
Então esse estirador sicado é um
indicador de cetoacidose diabética não
confunda com cetoacidose fisiológica que
é uma condição séria que pode surgir
como complicações do diabete
Especialmente quando não é devidamente
controlado então a cetoacidose diabética
ocorre quando o corpo na falta de
glicose acessível porque não tem
insulina para queimar em forma de
energia
devido esse problema da insuficiência de
insulina então começa a quebrar gorduras
como fonte alternativa esse processo
leva a produção de cetonas que são
responsáveis por cheiro adocicado
frutado característico além do ádito o
excesso de glicose pode ser excretado
pelos zins o que pode também tornar a
urina um cheiro doce ou frutado então
esse estado é extremamente perigoso não
confundir com cetose leve que é muito
bom para pessoas que têm pré-diabetes
tá então a CET acidose é muito
preocupante em idosos diabéticos requer
atenção imediata médica é uma emergência
médica portanto esse cheiro
característico não pode ser ignorado é
um sinal de alerta de que algo sério
pode estar acontecendo agora pessoal
outro problema grave que pode causar
odor é doença renal uma condição séria
que afeta a funcionalidade dos INSS que
são importantíssimos no processo de
filtragem e eliminação de resíduos do
nosso sangue então quando osens não
estão operando qu deviam devido a lesões
ou doenças a sua capacidade de remover
eficientemente as toxinas e os resíduos
e fica então prejudicada comprometida
então um dos resíduos que os rins
filtram do sangue é a ureia que
normalmente é expelida através da urina
no entanto se os rins não conseguem
filtrar a ureia apropriadamente ela
começa a ser acumulada no organismo e
ela pode se decompor em amônia que é um
composto com cheiro forte desagradável
esse cheiro de amônia pode ser
particularmente notável na urina mas em
estágios mais avançados da doença renal
crônica pode-se até perceber na
respiração da pessoa devido ao excesso
de ureia que é transferido pros pulmões
exalado resultando nesse hálito que
lembra cheiro de peixe ou amônia um odor
anormal na urina ou na respiração deve
ser um sinal de alerta para procurar
avaliação médica especialmente se
acompanhado de outros sintomas de doença
renal como é o caso de fadiga inchaço
que é o edema dificuldade de
concentração ou alterações na quantidade
na frequência urinária doenças renais
podem progredir de forma silenciosa e
muitas vezes sem sintomas no estádios
iniciais tornando importantíssima
conscientização diagnóstico precoce
outra doença com impacto no nosso odor
corporal é a doença do fígado doença
hepática porque ele representa um papel
muito importante atuando na
metabolização e desintoxicação de várias
substâncias
importantes por isso quando o fígado
está comprometido seja por doença
cirrose ou esteatose ou qualquer dano
que seja a sua capacidade de processar
eliminar essa substância de maneira
eficiente é afetada então entre as
substâncias que o fígado processa estaba
e rubina juntamente com outras toxinas
que quando não são adequadamente
metabolizadas devido a doença do fígado
doença hepática começam a se acumular no
corpo Então esse acúmulo pode levar ao
que é conhecido como odor corporal
característico da cirrose que é uma das
manifestações mais sérias da doença
hepática Então essas pessoas que TM essa
situação doenças hepáticas podem exibir
um cheiro parecido com mofo ou terra
molhada tanto no hálito quanto na urina
sabe quando está um tempo quente e
começa a chover aquele cheiro de terra
molhada que pode até ser confundido com
mofo Então esse udor também pode
apresentar nuances doces ou Metálicas em
alguns casos pode até lembrar o cheiro
de enxofre então esses sinais olfatórios
olfativos embora não sejam os únicos
sintomas de doença hepática são
importantes indicadores de que algo pode
não estar dentro dos conformes com o
fígado outros sintomas de doença
hepática pode incluir amarelamento da
pele e dos olhos que é chamada icterícia
inchaço abdominal também conhecido como
acite fadiga e alteração na cor da urina
e das
feses agora vamos falar sobre uma das
condições mais desafiadoras o câncer
pessoal o câncer é caracterizado por um
crescimento celular normal desordenado
descontrolado que pode ocorrer em
qualquer parte do corpo dependendo do
tipo e da localização do tumor o cân
pode resultar em diferentes odores uma
vez que as células tumorais liberam
compostos orgânicos voláteis específicos
os cães que T um ofato muito apurado têm
sido estudados por sua capacidade de
detectar esses odores específicos que
são associados ao câncer o que abre
perspectivas interessantes paraa
detecção precoce da doença com nossos
melhores amigos então eles sinalizam o
que encontram de formas que são
treinados como sentar latir ou dar a
pata por exemplo câncer de pulmão pode
também alterar o odor do hálito que pode
ser descrito como doce de terra essa
alteração no hálito reflete os compostos
liberados pelas células cancerígenas nos
pulmões da mesma forma o câncer de mama
pode influenciar odor do suor resultando
um aroma que pode ser descrito como
frutado floral ou até levemente picante
no caso do câncer de pele é possível que
um odor de extinto seja perceptível na
pele que é afetada pelo tumor é descrito
como ah rançoso azedo até mesmo cheiro
de queimado como médico enfatizo a
importância de Estar atento aos sinais
do nosso corpo incluindo mudança do odor
e buscar sim avaliação médica quando
algo parece Fora do Comum a prevenção e
diagnóstico precoce são fundamentais na
luta contra Qualquer que seja a doença
eu espero que essa conversa essas
informações tenham ajudado tenham
esclarecido algumas dúvidas e quem sabe
te inspirado a cuidar mais da sua saúde
da Saúde da sua família muito obrigado
pela sua atenção um grande abraço um
beijo no seu coração e você é fera